good morning hank it's tuesday so lately
my books especially looking for alaska
and turtles all the way down have been
removed from libraries and schools in
the u.s due to their purported obscenity
i've talked about book betting before
and i don't want to talk about it
directly today instead i want to talk
about what i think books do and why i
write them so half my life ago i worked
as a student chaplain at a children's
hospital and while there i saw much of
what i consider obscene i saw children
die i saw parents terrified not just
about whether their kids would survive
emergency surgery but also about how
they would ever pay for the accompanying
medical bills i saw things i don't care
to repeat all of it obscene but the fact
that i was a chaplain often surprises
people who are familiar with me or my
work i think it surprises many
evangelical christians because they
don't understand why a fellow christian
would intentionally pollute the minds of
young people with books that include
premarital sex and alcohol abuse and of
course it also surprises many people who
aren't religious because they're like
why would a seemingly thoughtful person
believe that every sunday all around the
world bad wine suddenly turns into god's
blood now i don't generally talk much
about my personal beliefs online because
you know this is the internet and i
don't wanna but i continue to find
religion a helpful approach to the
ancient conversation about how to live
as a person in a world full of other
people that said one of the first things
i learned as a chaplain is that it's not
about me and it's definitely not about
my beliefs right because like if
somebody drowning in an ocean of grief
said to me that their loved one had no
afterlife it was not my job to question
that and if somebody told me that their
loved one was now in heaven it wasn't my
job to question that either my job was
to listen to really listen i wasn't
there to solve or fix their pain which
could not be solved or fixed i was there
to hear their pain and acknowledge it as
my supervisor often told me don't just
do something
stand there and that is what i have
tried to do with my work i have tried to
write books that don't just do something
they stand there i believe that by just
standing there without judgment stories
can proclaim the full humanity of their
characters and in doing so can help us
to see the humanity within ourselves but
just as importantly stories also invite
us into other lives they help each of us
to understand the richness and
complexity of people who aren't like us
and in that sense i kind of understand
book banning because i think books are a
threat to many contemporary power
structures because many of those power
structures want us to see other people
especially marginalized people whether
they're marginalized because of race or
sexuality or gender identity or mental
illness or whatever
power structures want us to see those
people as less than fully human and so i
would argue that if great books have an
agenda it is not a liberal agenda or a
gay agenda or a christian agenda it is a
humanizing agenda a mission to recognize
and acknowledge the human value in
ourselves and others so hank in my faith
tradition we are called in the gospel of
matthew not just to treat our friends or
our neighbors as we ourselves would want
to be treated or to treat people with
similar value systems as we ourselves
would want to be treated we are called
to treat all others as we would want to
be treated to me that does not mean
deciding on someone else's behalf what
books they should be allowed to read nor
does it mean hiding from high school
students the realities of the human
condition both sexual and otherwise to
me what it means is working to make
space so that others all others can be
treated both by individuals and by
society with the same rights dignity and
respect that i would want for me or for
my family and i think efforts to
restrict stories are often efforts to
restrict empathy that's not in keeping
with my faith but more importantly i
don't think it's in keeping with a
functioning society hank i'll see you on
friday